i never want people to think that i'm
coming out to
change the narrative or to brush over
and not take responsibility for my
actions and
now that i have this gay life that i
don't have to address
my past as a straight man in a new
interview with variety
colton underwood is opening up about the
backlash
surrounding his coming out there was a
lot of learning experiences for me from
hearing some of the harsh criticism and
hearing some of the feedback that i was
getting
and it helped me and just helped me
grow as a human being last month the
former bachelor star revealed publicly
for the first time that he's gay during
a sit-down interview with good morning
america
i came to terms with that earlier this
year and have been processing it
and the next step in all of this was
sort of
letting people know still nervous but um
yeah it's it's been a journey for sure
following the interview
news broke that the 29 year old former
football pro was set to star in a new
netflix reality series
documenting his life as an openly gay
man
but shortly after a petition was created
on change.org
to cancel the project highlighting
allegations of abuse against colton
during his relationship with
then-girlfriend cassie randolph
how are you doing hi i'm good how are
you good good i'm cassie
colton the two met during season 23 of
the bachelor
and called it quits in may 2020 after
more than a year of dating
a source at the time told et that
following their breakup
cassie began to receive strange texts
from an unknown number
and allegedly found a tracking device on
her car
according to the source cassie
confronted colton and he admitted to
everything
cassie was granted a restraining order
against colton which she
later dropped i've ran for myself for 29
years
and there is no excuse
for any behavior of mine that was
holding on to this straight identity
or that was operating out of fear
of being gay and being outed now colton
opens up in the latest issue of variety
saying he has regrets about his past
behavior
what i did to cassie and my friends
and her family and what i put them
through
was so wrong and
i'm so sorry and
i think selfishly
i'm very upset with myself that i might
not ever have closure
and i might not ever be able to
apologize
in a satisfactory manner for not only
her but for everybody
and i think that's what hurts colton
says he has not reached out to cassie
following his gma
interview and he admits he never came
out to her
i never had the courage to talk to her
while we were in a relationship and
especially after
and while colton says he and cassie have
an agreement not to speak
publicly about the details surrounding
their split i know people
have a lot of questions but people also
need to realize we
we have an agreement together to not
talk about it he does
explain why he thinks he acted the way
he did at the end of their relationship
i think i knew in my heart of hearts
that cassie was like my last straight
relationship
and she was somebody who i loved and
fell in love with
and someone in that i thought
could make me straight i don't know if i
will ever get closure
be able to forgive myself for some of
the things that i said and did and
i just like vow and promise to move
forward in
a positive direction and never repeat
those and that's all i can
you